the bullet killing him entering his body
through the bulletproof vest that he was
supposed to it was actually designed to
protect him and police officials cast
out that any vest would have saved him
and hundreds of officers wear that vest
every day Ryan mathey joins us live
outside Metro Police Headquarters
tonight with the Dilemma this poses to
officers
yeah Brian Denise not all bulletproof
vets are created equal the one that
officer Tai was wearing exposed parts of
his body that left him partially
vulnerable and many officers Nationwide
wear similar vests that put them at the
same risk of this same fate
Metro investigators say a gunshot wound
to the abdomen killed officer Trump Tai
last week in the side
um
the round penetrated his ballistic vest
assistant Sheriff Andrew Walsh saying
the bullet went through the side of Ty's
bulletproof vest where his body was not
protected I don't know too many vests
that will stop a 762 round Steve gramis
is president of the Las Vegas Police
Protection Association a union
representing thousands of metro police
officers an officer can't go out in a
full tactical gear like a SWAT guy so
instead officers wear vests like this
the Department of Justice labeling it
protection level 3A that protects
against most handgun rounds but none
from a rifle the Clark County district
attorney describing the rifle pistol
hybrid that 24 year old Tyson Hampton
allegedly shot with as a gun used to
quote kill a lot of people I don't think
with what we saw a different vest plays
a role I really don't but why don't
officers wear more protection it would
be probably the most uncomfortable thing
that you could not put your arms down
you know along with how uncommon
encountering a gun like this is but the
boss ability still leaving officers at
risk there's potential for whatever they
are wearing out on the streets to not be
enough to protect them absolutely
now he adds that metro police officers
do get a yearly clothing allowance but
that allowance is meant to cover several
costs uniforms vests tools every single
year and that could easily be exceeded
as he says that the most expensive and
protective vest on the market can go
upwards of fifteen hundred dollars
reporting live outside the Metro
headquarters Ryan Matthey 8 News Now
so we reached out to other agencies here
in the valley on this North Las Vegas
Police say they do provide a vest but
the officer must pay to upgrade if they
want to Nevada State Police adds they
both purchased the vest and upgrade it
every five years and similarly
Nationwide the policy actually varies by
agency